in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Reggie
is with us how are you Reggie I'm doing
well how about yourself Dave I'm doing
pretty good so a gazelle on your shirt
it says I'm debt-free and what's the
rest of it say it well the Western would
say on the back after time for some pre
free plus ectomy okay schedule your free
flash secta me here okay good so you are
now officially a plastic surgeon oh yeah
what's the letters I can't see small
that is dumb cast is king oh that's why
I'm dead free I love it great shirt man
Mickey very cool so where do you live
I'm in Little Rock Arkansas on and
you're here to do your debt-free scream
obviously and how much have you paid
officer I've paid off forty-one thousand
dollars cool and how long did that take
you about two and a half years and I
paid about half of that and from March
to September of this year with an extra
job whoa kicked it into gear I did it's
a job okay so making what kind of money
during this two-and-a-half year started
fifty five thousand dollars and I ended
up at the end with $70,000 with extra
job okay and now we don't have to do
those exactly I hear you so tell me
about your journey two and a half years
I'll start with what kind of debt is
this it was a little bit everything just
normal so I had $15,000 on student loans
$15,000 credit cards $10,000 in my car
and about $1,000 in medical bills you
were classic yeah yeah well you're a
full-blown America and and now you still
are but you are a debt-free one fair
yeah so all right what happened over the
two and a half years what started this
and tell me how the story goes well
always try to do it on my own just pay
off credit cards and I would pay one off
and then get back into debt and then
they were passing out FPU flyers off at
church and as they were going out and I
took one and I'm a very structured
person person and went to the preview
class and that you laid out the plan for
us and I was sold you had showed us how
to budget and and been doing that ever
since in and that's that's that's what
got me here you know just by doing a
budget and sticking with it okay so you
had Financial Peace University flyer
handled at church you were just kind of
limping along thinking you ought to do
it but didn't know how exactly and then
Financial Peace University gives you the
and you jump on board and go mmm very
cool yes I teach it to others I've been
teaching three classes with a bundle on
Michael bunch so we've finished up our
last class for this semester last
Tuesday also they're all listening right
now ah very cool got their coordinator
here on the radio that's perfect
all right and then something happened
last year around March what was the deal
last year on March that's when you pick
up all the extra jobs you go crazy you
pay half of it since March yeah this
Marta took up a job at Papa John's and
start delivering pizzas what changed
what made you do that um well a lot of
my extracurricular activities stopped
while I was serving in Churchill ID and
doing other things and I just kind of
found myself just sitting around doing
nothing and I was like I could be paying
off money with this time just wasting so
on I got a job got pizza gig um it's
kind of a thing about is the year before
I went in to Papa John's in and then I
left out I chickened out she hired me
right on the spot and I was like I can
do this and so a year later I went back
in you know and I got the job she hired
me right on the spot again and and I
started working five days a week okay so
how much money you make five days a week
delivering pictures hundred dollars just
like you said $1,500 yep yeah I started
five days a week then went down to four
halfway through just cuz it was so crazy
but still made about the same amount of
money and that all went towards debt
everything yeah mathematically it was
found money yeah it was it was kind of
sad because I would come home with cash
and I couldn't do anything with it's
like I'm throwing it away in the garbage
basically I remember the time I was
throwing that cash away yeah that's
great very fun so when you're teaching
these classes your now success story
you've worked extra you worked a system
you worked a plan you work the clear
path you work this through and you paid
off forty-one thousand dollars and two
and a half years making fifty five
thousand before you picked up the extra
jobs when people ask you how did you do
that what are you telling the secret to
getting out of debt is I say you have to
start with finding out why you got there
in the first place for me it was a lot
of comfort
I got my first job in Little Rock and
then you know I was kind of trying to
keep up with the Joneses I was
everything I wanted the iPhone the
computer you know I was just buying
whatever I wanted my birthday I bought a
TV for myself you know and that's a
birthday night exactly and it was just
you know downhill from there and you
have to find why you got there for me
was that comfort Idol that we talked
about as Christians until you know you
have to realize that you comfort it
can't be found in the creative things
you can only be found in Jesus Christ
and you have to come to that low porn
you just pray and ask God you know why
how did I get here and then he'll show
you how you got there and it'll show you
how to get out and you tell you to rely
on him through the whole journey and
that really would help me stick through
that piece of job and go in with a smile
like like kind of like you talked about
you know you come in you show up and you
smile for the customers and you do your
job and you work hard
so godliness with contentment is great
gain
exactly it relaxes you in a place you
didn't even realize you were striving in
yeah yeah I keep I always was running
around and it kind of sounds like a
different version of what you're saying
but similar thinking if I could get this
I'll be happy yeah I'll be happy when I
get this right and that's like that's
like kind of comfort I believe me well
you call it comfort Idol it's a neat
neat way of saying it but yeah and I
remember all those years ago it's it's
so many years ago now but it doesn't
matter still it's still real fresh in my
spirit the first time I went in Sam's or
Costco and left without buying anything
because I thought it was federal law yet
about two hundred bucks how many went in
there yeah it's just like okay I now
have control of me wow what a neat idea
what a different thing what a different
way of looking at it and well
congratulation thank you so much how's
it feel it feels wonderful
feels great to keep the paycheck it
feels great to see my account it doesn't
deplete down you know to zero it goes up
now for the first time in my life you
know money actually accumulates on the
station stays in my saving account you
live like no one else now you can live
and give exactly no one else in show
very very cool how old are you I'm 30 so
this year
congratulations what do you do for a
living I'm a software developer had a
financial technology company and I
actually work in the deposit side of
things so yeah kind of weird if I was
working on the loan side you know I
really work in the deposit side of home
as well do some deposits very cool all
right Reggie from Little Rock Arkansas
$41,000 paid off in two and a half years
making fifty five and then up to 70
including pizza delivery count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three -
well done sir oh that's fabulous good
stuff that's why we have folks on just
like that
this guy did it man hey that's
incredible what a hero what an absolute
hero very well done